this is a production of cornell
university
so uh thank you everyone um for joining
my talk so for those of you that don't
know me my name is josh garcia and i'm
currently a fifth year phd candidate i'm
here in the department of horticulture
um so i'm actually getting ready to
graduate this summer and so for today's
horticulture seminar session i'll
kind of be taking a look back with you
all and sharing a little bit about my
phd dissertation work um and in addition
i'll also take a couple minutes to kind
of talk about some of the other things
i've been involved with as a phd student
um and also talk a little bit about
my next steps and kind of how it all
comes together to sort of inform my
goals and
goals going forward
and so yeah so thank you all again for
being here it's really great to see you
all and it really means a lot to me um
that showed up to support um and yeah
i'm really looking forward to um having
um this discussion with you all today
okay there we go okay so i actually
wanted to start off with my
acknowledgements just to make sure i had
enough time to properly think and
acknowledge everyone um so first and
foremost i wanted to thank my amazing
dissertation committee um jenny
gowniffan jim giovannoni and gensparx
for all of their amazing mentorship and
guidance throughout the whole phd
process
um i also wanted to thank all of my
amazing lab mates in the gown and fit
lab both past and present for all of
their help and support throughout the
years and for just making our lab such a
great place to work in
i also wanted to thank some various
friends and mentors of mine so i'd like
to thank lynne marie johnson at the
cornell statistical consulting unit for
helping me out with the computational
aspects of my work i'd also like to
thank dr sarah hernandez the associate
dean of uh inclusion and student
engagement on campus for being such a
great friend and mentor to me and other
marginalized students on campus i'd also
like to thank dr draina samuel who's the
associate director for the cornell
center for teaching innovation for being
one of my biggest teaching mentors and
really helping me develop my teaching
portfolio
i'd also like to thank one of my
earliest mentors dr amelie godin who was
the one who really inspired me to go
into agricultural research and i'd also
like to thank dr sarah pearls who's one
of my nearest and dearest friends and
mentors who has helped me sort of
navigate academia in so many different
ways but i also wanted to give a special
thank you to the uc davis mcnair
scholars program
i always say without mcnair um i
probably wouldn't be in graduate school
so i want to give a special thank you to
everyone at mcnair um for believing in
me being invested in me and also giving
me the skills and confidence necessary
to get to and complete graduate school
um i also wanted to acknowledge all of
our different funding sources for this
work that i'm going to share with you
all so i'd like to thank the usda need
for grant as well as the nsf grfp on the
atkinson sustainable biodiversity fund
and the mcnair suny diversity fellowship
and so with that we'll go ahead and get
into the science so what i study in my
work our plant associated microbiomes
and a microbiome for those of you that
don't know or need a refresher is just
the collection of microbial cells in a
given environment um they're basically
everywhere they're on your chairs right
now they're up in the air um you can
find them out in the environment and you
can also find them in and around plants
and in the case of plant microbiomes all
the different compartments of a plant
from the roots to the shoots to the
leaves all harbor taxonomically and
functionally distinct microbiomes and to
kind of illustrate this i have this
figure from hopeful and gupta 2016 which
just shows all the different
compartments of a plant and all the
different microbiomes that are
associated with these compartments so we
have the phylosphere microbiome which
consists of microbes that live on the
leaves and stems of the plant
we have the endothelic microbiome which
consists of microbes that live within
the plant tissue itself and then we have
the rhizosphere and soil microbiomes
which are the microbes that live in soil
and interact with the plant via the
plant roots
and so what i'm interested in looking at
in my work specifically is the
rhizosphere microbiome and the
rhizosphere just to give a definition is
the area of soil that's under direct
influence of a plant host
so it's basically a sort of the soil
interface that exists between a plant
root and the bulk soil environment and
what makes the rhizosphere really
interesting is that it's sort of this
hot spot for biodiversity and within the
rhizosphere you can find all sorts of
organisms including bacteria archaea
fungi viruses worms arthropods basically
everything and with this really sort of
rich biodiversity there's the potential
for a lot of complex ecological
interactions to take place that actually
influence various aspects of plant
growth and development
and vice versa the plant host also
influences different aspects of the
rhizosphere microbiome as well
and so for my dissertation i had this
sort of very broad overarching research
question of how do microbial consortia
in the rhizosphere influence
horticultural crop traits and production
and my transportation was a little
unconventional and that rather than
doing one big project like i feel like
dissertations typically are i actually
did four smaller projects um but all the
projects are tangentially related to
each other they all sort of led to and
fed into one another um and again they
all go back to this sort of central
research question that i have sketched
out here
so to give you an overview of the
dissertation chapters that i'm going to
discuss in my presentation um i have
them sketched out here uh my chapter one
was a literature review that we
published in frontiers of microbiology
and in this review we discussed the
application of concepts and
methodologies from other disciplines to
rhizosphere microbiome research and
given that that chapter was just a
literature review i'm not really going
to discuss it
in the rest of the presentation um but
again it's um published um in front of
user microbiology if you're interested
in reading a little bit more about it uh
my chapter two was a multi-generation
growth chamber experiment where we were
interested in promoting plant
productivity in brassica rapa through an
artificial group selection process
my chapter three was a greenhouse
experiment that i worked on over at
boyce johnson institute and in that
project we were interested in utilizing
plant transcriptomics to understand how
beneficial microbiomes alter tomato
foliar and fruit traits and then my
final chapter was a field based project
that i received funding to complete from
the cornell atkinson center for
sustainability and in that project we
were interested in understanding the
effects of intercropping on soil
properties and horticultural production
systems um so you see with all my
dissertation chapters you know we're
working with a lot of different plants
we're using uh we're working in a lot of
different contexts and using a lot of
sort of different research methodologies
but again all these different projects
are going back to this central research
question and again they all get at some
sort of aspect of plant rhizosphere
interactions
and so i'll start off by discussing my
chapter two work so my chapter two was
again a multi-generation growth chamber
experiment where we were interested in
promoting plant productivity in brass
curator through an artificial group
selection process
so to give a little bit of background
and ration now for this experiment what
sort of motivated us to pursue this
project was this idea of group selection
and group selection is this theory from
evolutionary biology that states that
natural selection can act on whole
groups of organisms in addition to
individuals as initially proposed by
darwin and to kind of illustrate this i
have this figure um from my chapter one
actually where we show all the different
sort of biological levels associated
with microbiomes and what group
selection theory states is that there
are selective pressures at all these
different sort of levels that are
constantly interacting with one another
and sort of counteracting one another to
influence the absurd phenotype of a
microbial population
and so um in the case of plants we know
that plants in the rhizome sphere
already do sort of group selection like
processes um and we know that when
plants grow in stressful conditions they
can actually enrich their rhizosphere
for microbial taxa that confer specific
fitness advantages and to illustrate
this i have on this adaptive figure from
you at all 2021.
on the left side you can see a plant
growing in nitrogen limited soil what it
has the potential to do in this
situation is actually enrich its
rhizosphere via root exudation
for microbial tax so that's cycle
nitrogen
and by enriching its rhizosphere for
those microbes that um do that specific
activity the plant then um experiences
enhanced uh an uptake and just more
broadly growth promotion
and so we know that again plants are
doing this sort of group selection in
the rhizosphere already and so for this
experiment what we wanted to see is if
it's possible to sort of artificially
select for whole groups of microbes that
promote plant productivity and sort of
engender this process
artificially in a controlled environment
and so for this experiment we did a
multi-generation selection experiment
where we tried to develop microbiomes in
the rhizosphere that enhanced plant
productivity
so we first started off by gathering a
single breast graph a seed pool and then
we planted an initial generation of
these seeds in sterilized potting soil
that was actually treated with a
microbial inoculant created from organic
farm soils and then once we planted
these seeds we then assigned each pot to
one of three random selection treatments
so we had a high biomass selection
treatment where we tried to select from
microbiomes that enhance productivity
and we used above ground biomass
production as sort of our proxy for
other aspects of plant productivity
we had a random selection line where we
checked to select for random microbes
and that was to sort of control for our
selection process and then we had a
non-adapted control line which was not
undergoing any sort of selection
and so we repeated the selection process
for a total of nine generations and then
after each generation recorded plant
phenotypes and microbial responses to
try to look at what the effect of our
different selection treatments were on
microbial composition and plant
phenotypes
and so i'll start off by talking about
some of our plant phenotype data so here
we have plant phenotypes for generation
nine which was the final generation in
the experiment after uh microbiomes had
undergone selection and what was really
interesting was that despite the fact
that we were selecting for microbes that
were associated with above-ground
biomass production we didn't see um
enhanced biomass production in the high
biomass selection line but what was
really interesting was that when we
looked at other aspects of plant
productivity we did see some sort of
interesting patterns emerge amongst the
three different selection treatments so
we have um in figure a on the left side
we have c shields and you can see that c
gel is significantly greater in the high
biomass selection treatment
compared to the random the control
treatment while the random treatment
doesn't differ between the other two and
then when we look at nitrogen economic
use efficiency which is defined as the
gram of seed produced per the gram of
nitrogen added we see again a similar
pattern emerge where nitrogen agronomic
use deficiency is higher in the high
biomass treatment compared to the
control treatment and the random
treatment again doesn't differ between
the other two
and so putting this phenotype data
together uh what this all suggests is
that again um through our selection
process we maybe didn't alter above
ground biomass production but we may
have altered these other aspects of
plant productivity via our selection on
the rhizosphere microbiome
and so in addition to the plant
phenotyping we also did some microbial
analysis on microbial communities in the
rhizosphere so here um i have our
ordination and just to make sure we're
all on the same page i wanted to take a
minute to kind of explain what an
ordination is and how we use them in
rhizosphere microbiome research so what
an ordination is is a graphing method
where you plot samples based off of
community composition and so each
individual point that you're seeing on
the plot represents a specific sample
and
the way ordination works is that the
closer two samples are together on the
plot the more alike and community
composition they are and the further two
examples are from one another the more
dissimilar and community composition
they are
and so in this ordination we wanted to
look at the effect of selection
treatment and generation on microbial
composition we have our different
selection treatments represented by
different shapes we have the high
biomass treatment represented by circles
the random treatment represented by
triangles and the control treatment for
all generation sequence represented by
these aqua colored crosses
and then for the high biomass and random
selection treatments we have our
different generations represented by
these rainbow colors and you can see
that as the generations progress we get
sort of divergence in microbial
community composition between the three
different selection treatments which was
also verified on using quantitatively
using carminova which you see on the
upper left-hand side you can see in our
purple nova that there are um
statistics statistically significant
effects of generation selection
treatment and the interaction between
the two on microbial composition
and so what this ordination is showing
us is that through our selection process
we
developed these unique microbial
communities in these three different
selection treatments which again may
help us explain some of the differences
in breast crapa phenotype that we were
seeing
and then to take our microbial analysis
a step further we also did some network
modeling using extended local similarity
analysis or elsa
and i won't get too technical with what
an elsa is but basically what it is is a
network modeling method that allows you
to compare microbial interaction
networks between treatments and so for
our elsa what we were interested in
looking at was the effect of our
selection treatment on microbial
interactions and you can see in figure a
we have our three different um
treatments uh represented by these
different colored interaction networks
and you can see just visually that there
do appear to be some differences in
interaction that works between the three
treatments and these differences become
even more apparent when we overlay the
networks on top of one another which is
what you see in figure b more
specifically what i have circled there
is a more dense microbial interaction
network in the high brow mass selection
treatment compared to both the random
and controlled treatments
and so what this is suggesting is that
through our selection process we not
only developed these unique microbial
communities taxonomically we also
altered microbial interaction networks
and microbial activities and that's
really interesting from a rhizosphere
microbiome standpoint because it
suggests that through our selection
process we develop these microbiomes
that may be coordinating some sort of
group level activity such as plant
growth promotion
and so to put it all together what this
data all suggests is that through our
selection process um uh again our
phenotype shows our phenotype data shows
that we altered cgos and nitrogen
ergonomic use efficiency in the high
biomass selection treatment compared to
the control treatment our sequencing
data shows that bacterial community
composition and interaction networks
were both altered in response to
selection and these changes in bacterial
taxonomic composition and activity may
help us explain some of the differences
in plant phenotype that we were seeing
and so very broadly this experiment is
really interesting because it shows that
through altering microbial community
composition and interaction networks we
can alter different plant traits and so
to go back to this sort of central
research question of is it possible to
artificially select for whole groups of
microbes in the rhizosphere um this data
suggests that it is indeed a possibility
um and so that's my chapter two work and
so this project is as jenny mentioned um
soon to be published in communications
biology um so hopefully within the next
month or so um it'll be out if you're
interested in reading a little bit more
um about this work
and so that was my chapter two work and
so now i wanted to move on to discussing
my chapter 3 project so again my chapter
3 was a greenhouse experiment that i
worked on over at boyce thompson
institute
and in this experiment we were
interested in utilizing plant
transcriptomics to understand how
beneficial microbiomes alter tomato
foliage and fruit traits so to give a
little bit of rationale for this
experiment um oftentimes when people
study want to study what the effect of a
rhizosphere microbiome is on a plant
host um they rely on phenotyping to sort
of report what the effects of
microbiomes are on specific plants which
isn't necessarily bad but we know that
microbiomes interact with plant hosts in
a variety of different ways and can um
alter plant phenotypes through a variety
of different mechanisms that maybe
aren't so evident through plant
phenotyping alone
and so for this experiment we wanted to
sort of toy around with this idea of
using molecular methods such as plant
transcriptomics or rna sequencing to
sort of report how microbiomes are
altering plant gene expression and
developmental processes um and so the
microbiomes that we decided to work with
in this experiment were direct from
vermicompost and vermicompost for those
of you that don't know is just a soil
amendment that's actually created from
worm castings
and we decided to work with birming
compost because previous research has
shown that it has beneficial effects on
tomato plant productivity um which is
shown here in this picture that i have
from a study that dr neal matson in our
department actually did and you can see
that as we increase the percentage of
very compost in these tomato plants we
get consistently enhanced above ground
biomass production in tomato and so we
know that vermicompost has this
beneficial effects on um tomato plants
and so for this experiment we wanted to
look at what the sort of microbial
contributions to this growth promotion
may be
and so for our overarching sort of
research question or goal for this
experiment um it was kind of two-pronged
so first and foremost we wanted to see
again what the effect of microbes from
vermicompost are on tomato traits and
then we also wanted to again see
if it's possible to sort of use
transcriptomics as a sort of method to
look at what the effects of these
microbiomes are
and so for this experiment we had done
uh we again did a greenhouse um trial
where we grew tomato plants with one of
three microbial inoculants and then
looked at what their effect was on
tomato plant phenotypes and
transcriptomic profiles
so we planted tomato seedlings in the
greenhouse and then treated them with
one of three inoculants we had a
vermicompost microbial inoculant which
was a liquid microbial broth created
from vermicompost we had a heat treated
vermicompost inoculate which was a
liquid broth created from twice
autoplayed fermi compost which was to
kind of control for the effects of a
nutrients from the vermicompost and then
we had a control treatment which was
just a sterilized microbial growth broth
so i didn't receive any sort of
microbial communities
and so we treated the plants with these
inoculants and then we grew the plants
to maturity in a greenhouse and then
along the way recorded plant phenotypes
including above ground biomass
production foliar nitrogen content and
cg are
fruit yield and we also looked at um
microbiome composition um to try to
compare microbial community composition
between these three treatments um and we
also did some foliar and fruit um
transcriptomics to look at what the
effect of these treatments were on
tomato gene expression
and so i'll start off by talking about
our microbial data in this experiment so
here we have another ordination
comparing rhizosphere microbial
communities between our three different
treatments
so here we're looking at the effect of
treatment on microbial composition and
we have our three treatments represented
by these different colors we have the
vermicompost treatment in red the heat
treated vermicompost treatment and blue
and the control treatment in green
and what you can see here is that
despite there being a pretty large
amount of variability in the data there
do seem to be these three sort of loose
clusters forming amongst of the three
treatment groups which suggests that
there are significant effects of
treatment on microbial composition which
we again verified quantitatively um with
the permanova which you can see on the
upper right hand side and so what this
is showing us is that through our
inoculation method we cultivated these
unique microbial communities in these
three treatments in the greenhouse which
is great that's what we wanted and so we
hypothesized that if we cultivated these
unique microbial communities we would
see some differences in tomato plant
phenotype more specifically we
hypothesized that we would see enhanced
productivity in my tomato plants that
were grown with the vermicompost
microbiomes
but what was really interesting was that
when we looked at our plant pinot type
data we didn't see the sort of effects
that we were hypothesizing at all
and in fact most tomato plant phenotypes
actually remained unchanged um so here
uh we have total above ground biomass
production foliar nitrogen content and
fruit size um you can see that there is
an effective treatment on above ground
biomass production and it seems to
increase in the vermicompost and heat
treated very compost treatments and then
when we looked at foliar delta n15
values which is a proxy for soil
nitrogen cycling we saw that it was
significantly different between all
three treatments and foliar delta n15
was actually the highest and the heat
treated very compost treatment so this
kind of had a scratching our heads
because again this was not at all what
we were expecting um but what was really
interesting was when we did our
transcriptomic profiling that's when we
sort of started to see um the
patterns that we were hypothesizing so
here i have our transcript our foliar
transcriptome um for our different
tomato plants and so we have um here the
expression of different uh key plant
nutrient transporters so we have the
expression of copper nitrate phosphate
and zinc transporters between our three
treatments in this experiment and you
can see that consistently for all of
these different nutrient transporters we
get
up regulation of all of these uh
transporters and the vermicompost
treatment compared to um both control
treatments and
in addition to that foliar transcriptome
data we also did some fruit
transcriptomics to look at what the
effect of these different microbial
treatments are on fruits and we saw um
again similar patterns sort of emerge on
the left side we have the expression of
cell wall protein x-77373
which is actually involved in tomato
fruit disease resistance and you can see
here that the expression of that protein
is again
significantly upregulated in the
vermicompost treatment and in figure b
we have the expression of chlorophyll a
b binding proteins and you can see that
again their expression is also
upregulated in the vermicompost
treatment
and so to put it all together what this
experiment shows is that again we have
unique um rhizosphere bacterial
communities between our three treatments
and this experiment we hypothesized that
if we had these unique microbial
communities we would see some
differences in plant phenotypes but um
and again more specifically we
hypothesized that we would see growth
promotion um in the vermin compost
treatment um but we didn't observe um
those patterns um but what was really
interesting again was that when we did
um our transcriptomic sequencing that's
when we started to see effects of
vermicompost microbiomes and if it
wasn't for our transcriptomic sequencing
we wouldn't have picked up on these sort
of growth promoting effects that vermee
compost has
on on tomato plants and so um so go back
to that again research question of you
know how do vermicompost microbiomes
influence tomato growth and development
what this experiment shows is that
vermicompost microbiomes actually
confirm multiple fitness advantages to
tomato plants including the upregulation
of nutrient transporter genes and
disease resistance genes um and again
this was all evidenced through our
transcriptomic sequencing um and so
that's my chapter three work and so this
project is currently um in preparation
for publication and bmc plant biology um
and so hopefully it'll be out soon if
you're interested in reading a little
bit more about it um and i wanted to
before i move on give a special shout
out to my undergraduate mentee michaela
moravec who graduated um last year um
and got an amazing job in massachusetts
and she's actually going to be a
co-author um on this paper so i'm really
proud of her for all the work she did
here um and all the amazing things she
continues to do um and so that's my
chapter three work and so now i wanted
to move on to my fourth and final
chapter um so uh my fourth chapter was
again a field-based project that i
received funding for from the cornell
atkinson center for sustainability and
in this project we were interested in
looking at the effects of intercropping
on soil properties and horticultural
production systems so to give a little
bit of background for this experiment
previous research has shown that
enhancing biodiversity in agriculture
could promote multiple ecosystem
services um and to kind of give an
example i have this figure from finney
and k 2016 where they show that
consistently enhancing um biodiversity
and agriculture could promote ecosystem
services such as weed suppression and
nitrogen retention and above-ground
biomass nitrogen production
and so biodiversity
can have these beneficial effects on
agricultural systems and there's
multiple ways through which you can sort
of impose biodiversity in agriculture
and one of the ways that we were
interested in looking at in this
experiment was intercropping
so intercropping just to give a
definition is a simple farming method
where you grow more than one crop in a
field at a time and
previous research has shown that
intercropping can have several
beneficial effects on aggro ecosystems
more specifically mental cropping has
been shown to have beneficial effects on
pests and disease management and to kind
of give an example i have this data from
solvay at all 2016 where they show that
intercropping onion and lettuce together
um can significantly reduce um pest
pressure um in agroecosystems
and so um so for this project what we
wanted to look at was specifically how
intercropping alters soil properties
because that's kind of received less
attention in the inter-cropping research
and more specifically we wanted to look
at what the effect of inter-cropping was
on soil chemical and biological
properties as well as plant phenotypic
outcomes and production outcomes
and so for this experiment we did a
field trial over at caldwell's field
where we grew tomato plants in one of
three different field treatments so our
first treatment was our control
treatment where we just mono cropped
tomatoes
and then we had two inter-crop
treatments in this experiment so our
first intercrop treatment um consisted
of growing a tomato intercropped with
tobacco and the idea there was to see
what the effect of inter-cropping is
when we grow tomato with a close
solanaceous relative
and then our second inter-crop treatment
consisted of growing uh tomato with kale
and the idea there was to see what the
effect of growing tomato what the more
distantly related brassica crop is
and so we cultivated on these plots and
then throughout the growing season
recorded um soil and plant responses to
inter-crop treatment so look at what the
effect of inter-cropping was on
different soil properties
and in turn on plant phenotypic outcomes
and so i'll start off by uh talking
about some of our soil chemical data so
uh very broadly speaking when we looked
at our soil chemical data we saw several
effects of intercropping on uh on soil
nutrition but the pattern sort of
shifted um with each sort of uh nutrient
that we were looking at so in figure a
we have um soil nitrate and you can see
that soil nitrate is significantly
greater in the tobacco treatment
compared to both the monocrop and kale
treatment
but when we look at other um key soil
nutrients such as phosphorus we see sort
of different patterns emerge
so you can see i'm in figure b that soil
phosphorus is significantly greater in
the kl treatment compared to the tobacco
treatment while the monocrop treatment
again doesn't differ between the other
two
and so what this data is kind of showing
us is that intercropping does have
effects on soil chemistry and the
abundance of these different key plant
nutrients but it's all dependent on crop
combination and what's being cultivated
with one another
um and so in addition to that soil
chemical data we also um did some
microbial sequencing to look at what the
effect was on microbial composition um
so here we're looking at the effects of
treatment and sampling date on microbial
composition
for our sampling days we're specifically
looking at microbial communities at the
start of the experiment versus harvest
and it's kind of hard to see in this
ordination because there is a pretty
large amount of variability in the data
but quantitatively if you look on the
upper right hand side you can see our
permanova and you can see that there are
significant effects of treatment and
date on microbial composition but not
the interaction between the two
and so what this is showing us is that
in addition to altering those different
soil chemical properties um
intercropping also has effects on soil
biological properties and
microbial communities
in
agroecosystems
and then so in addition to looking at
all of that soil data we also looked at
some phenotypic outcomes um so we looked
at traits such as above ground biomass
production foliar nitrogen content and
fruit yields we didn't see any effect of
inter cropping on above above-ground
biomass production or foliar nitrogen
content but we did see significant
effects of inter-cropping on average
tomato fruit yields per plant and more
specifically you can see here that
average tomato fruit yield is
significantly greater in the tobacco
treatment compared to both the mono crop
and kale treatments so what that's
suggesting is that through intercropping
tomato with tobacco we can get
enhancement and yield and that may be
again due to some of the shifts and soil
properties that we were seeing
instead of summarize and put all the
data together um again what our
experiment shows is that changes in soil
chemical properties on implant nutrition
are dependent on what crops are being
intercropped with one another
soy bacteria communities um in this
experiment again shifted in response to
inter crop treatment showing that
intercropping can shift microbial
taxonomic composition um and also shifts
in soil properties could have resulted
again in the shifts and tomato fruit
yields that we were seeing
um and so this data is really um
exciting because it shows that
interpreting um again kind of going back
to um that brief kind of introduction
that i gave for this experiment um it
shows that intercropping can promote
multiple ecosystem services in
agriculture for example in the tobacco
treatment you know we saw enhanced
nitrate um and fruit yields and so to go
back to you know that central research
question of how does inter-cropping
alter soil properties
again this experiment shows that
intercropping alters different soil
chemical and biological properties but
again it's all dependent on what's being
cultivated with one another
and so uh with that that kind of wraps
up
my dissertation discussion and so with
the last couple minutes that i have for
my presentation time slot today i wanted
to talk just very briefly about some of
the other things that i've been involved
with as a graduate student um and also
my future plans and how again it kind of
all comes together to sort of inform my
goals going forward um so in addition to
you know my uh my research work and my
lab work and stuff i've also been
involved with various campus
organizations um so pictured here i have
um the latin x graduate student
coalition and as an executive board
member of lgsc for two years i actually
had the opportunity to
put together and facilitate a variety of
programming
that meant to support
marginalized students on campus
which was a lot of fun and i really
cherish all those memories and
connections i got to make through that
work um in addition to on my campus
leadership i've also been involved with
teaching and pedagogical training on
campus so as jenny discussed in my
introduction some of my teaching
highlights include serving as a plant
pathology ta for the prison education
program and also um teaching my own
class on scientific writing on to first
years on campus which were both a lot of
fun and um it really sort of deepened my
passion for stem education um and in
addition to my teaching work i've also
been involved with pedagogical training
on campus and this was mainly through um
the cornell center for teaching
innovation so as a cti fellow i've had
the opportunity to put together a
variety of programming meant to foster
inclusion and innovation and teaching um
and i put together a bunch of different
trainings and programs for graduate and
post-doctoral instructors on campus
which again um has all been really great
and has um really sort of again deepened
my um appreciation for and passion for
education um in addition to all that
campus um all my campus work i've also
been involved with different
organizations off campus so here i have
a picture from last summer um where i
got the opportunity to co-facilitate a
community gardening and climate
education summer camp for kids in
ithaca's west village um and this was
through black hands universal and so
here in the snapshot this was kind of
like a snapshot of our planting workshop
so i got to teach the kids about things
like um you know planting and um that
type of stuff and we've got to do some
like decorating around the garden and
everything um which is a lot of fun and
um yeah and so i think you know through
all of these different sort of um
experiences i really you know developed
a strong sort of passion for and um
appreciation for um you know community
collaboration camaraderie um all that
stuff and so going forward what my goal
is is to kind of sort of integrate all
of that a little bit more into my
research and so that brings me to my
post-doctoral plans so as jenny
mentioned in my introduction um this
fall i'll be heading back to um sunnier
days at uc davis
um and yeah at davis i'll be joining the
labs of dr christina loscano and dr
malika noko um and we're gonna be
working i'll be taking the lead on a big
field-based project in the california
central valley where i'm going to be
working with
farmers of color to look at how climate
smart management practices influence
drought fertility and structural
resiliency and almond orchards more
specifically we're going to be looking
at what the effects of cover cropping
and climate smart irrigation practices
are on almond root ecophysiology and
as well as different aspects of soil
health such as microbial community
composition soil carbon sequestration
and all of those different sort of um
properties um so i'm really excited for
my postdoc work um and
yeah and so with that um i just wanted
to end by saying thank you all once
again um for uh not only i guess coming
to my talk but for um yeah such a great
you know graduate school experience and
stuff um yeah i'm really gonna miss
cornell and um yeah i feel like i miss
everyone and so i hope that you know we
can all stay in touch and um with that
um about the last few minutes um i'll
take any questions or anything that you
all have um fun questions are welcome to
um if you want to ask me non-research
stuff
so thank you all um
hey josh great job and i'm really super
excited to hear that you're going to
start working in orchard systems yeah
of course
um so in your work i'm wondering a
little bit um like mechanistically what
might be happening
in the soils with the microbial
communities did you do any
sequencing and look at specific
taxonomic groups
are you looking you know is it like
specific organisms or groups of
organisms in the soil that are really
starting to show
their effect on increasing things like
you looked at like biomass of plants
right yeah so um yeah so we did look at
those things in my different projects um
for example in chapter two um again that
multi-generation growth chamber
experiment where we saw um changes in
breast carapa productivity um but we did
look at microbial community composition
our taxonomic abundances
and look at how generate we looked at
how generation and selection treatment
altered abundances of different um
bacterial families that are associated
with growth promotion um so we looked at
the abundances of oxalobacteria which
are involved with nitrogen cycling um
which we saw um was their abundances
were significantly greater and the high
biomass selection treatment so again
that may help us explain some of the
differences that we were seeing um and
so yeah to answer your question yeah we
did look at you know microbial
abundances and stuff i didn't really
have time to present it in this um you
know presentation but yeah we saw um in
all three experiments really changes in
the abundances of different um
beneficial microbes in the rhizosphere
that again may help us explain some of
those phenotypic differences we were
seeing um and yeah
yeah that would be really interesting to
look at that you decide to read your
papers um maybe with that too
in the apple world and probably other
crops too there's a lot of microbial
stimulants that are being sold right
sometimes even like you know this has a
certain suite of microbes in it and
things like that
um
what are your thoughts on that i think
there's there's is it is it a
snake oil or is it is there some benefit
to these products that are being sold
millions of dollars worth of money yeah
um so i guess i want to say that it's
like context-dependent
like
i don't know i guess like yeah like you
know you think about the research like
the research with like those microbial
inoculants and everything a lot of it is
like done in like the greenhouse and
stuff so which obviously
doesn't necessarily really scale up to
like field settings um so i guess like i
don't know controlled environments like
what neil is doing and stuff like that
maybe like you know those microbial
documents may be especially useful but
in terms of like feels
stuff i guess maybe like more i would
say more research is needed there um but
uh yeah
in the back then yeah
hi josh um amazing job i really am a
super huge fan of your work um i have a
couple of questions
first is about chapter two the elsa
network analysis i was wondering like
the the tightness of the network that
was in the
um
higher biomass treatment like what does
that distance represent
yeah so what you were seeing um in that
interaction network was um so all the
different lines were basically
representing interactions between
members of the microbial community and
so um if you'll remember um in the
higher mass selection treatment we saw
more um connections and lines between
all of those different members of the
microbial community and so what that's
suggesting is that um through our
selection treatment we um promoted
interactions um in the microbial
communities of that specific selection
line which again may help us explain
some of those differences in plant
phenotype that we were seeing um again
if those microbes are coordinating some
sort of activity like the production of
nitrogen cycling enzymes or something
that may help us you know again explain
some of those differences in plant
phenotypes that we were seeing oh i see
so it's like the interactions were just
clustered more so amongst certain
bacteria right yeah so there was
basically just more interactions amongst
microbial members um in the high bound
mass selection treatment okay
i have a question from that one can i um
that's some of the chat too so maybe one
more and then we got to go to chat okay
i just had to follow up to the the
networking was that another specific
analysis we did like before doing the
stats or was that a statistical analysis
yeah so that was uh i guess yeah so what
you were the graphs that you were seeing
was um what came after doing the
statistics so what elsa does is it
basically quantifies microbial interact
it uses um microbial co-occurrence data
to sort of infer relationships and
interactions amongst community members
um so what we did was we quantitatively
took those different sort of like scores
and then we made um the graphs that you
were saying cool there you go
i interrupt you let's get another one
yeah go ahead go ahead yeah okay um my
other question was a theme that came up
throughout like
multiple of your studies is that like
the changes in soil properties and
microbial communities couldn't always be
phenotypically observed um and so like
aside from seed production and fruit
yield what are some of the ways that
farmers can measure the beneficial
effects of
like changing soil properties right yeah
so i think some of the other ways are
maybe outside of the plant so like in
that postdoc we're going to be looking
at the effect of these different
management practices on like soil carbon
sequestration and stuff so maybe that
could be some other ways in which
farmers can kind of kick up on these
differences um i also think um i guess
just off the top of my head and stop
thinking about my transcriptomic data um
i mean i know like a farmer's not gonna
like you know do rna sequencing but i
guess that could be another way through
which you know you can look at these
sort of like effects um and again i was
like my transcript but my transcriptomic
sequencing showed um
yeah we wouldn't have picked up on those
effects if it wasn't for you know that
sequencing so um yeah i guess that could
be kind of another way through which to
look at the effects of microbiomes but
yeah
okay so if if you are online in zoom and
you had a question can you just unmute
and and give it to josh please
sure josh thank you for your research um
i was just wondering and this has kind
of already been addressed but your
chapter two research was done in a
greenhouse and i wondered to what extent
you think
those relationships would
be able to transfer if you were doing it
in a field experiment
right yeah so i think um yeah in terms
of uh doing it in like a field setting
i'm not sure if like
selecting for microbes maybe happen in
the same way like i don't know if we can
make a big microbial inoculate or
something from uh um for like a field
setting but i think uh like i guess like
i've thought about it like ever since
you know we did that experiment and
stuff and i guess like yeah if someone
were to ask me like how does that apply
to like field settings i guess like i'm
thinking like management practices so
maybe you know we're not gonna like take
soils from you know plants that have
enhanced biomass production and
inoculated into a new host in the field
but what we can do is um basically uh
sort of enrich the rhizosphere and soils
in these different sort of field
settings for um
these growth promoting bacteria through
management practices um so yeah i guess
like in the field i guess like what the
experiment shows is that um you know
again like these microbial communities
can be um manipulated to sort of um uh
uh lead to changes in plant phenotype
and maybe in the field um uh one of the
ways in which we can do that is through
management practices
right okay we are out of time if you
want to stick around um i do you have
time to stick around and yeah okay great
well please let's give
[Applause]
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu